do you want to learn more about your
past websites offer an introduction but
there's a group in las vegas that can go
much deeper so how do you start such a
big job to find out about your heritage
well john langler found one person
willing to try
the nostalgia is everywhere we're a very
close-knit family snapshots of a family
tree stretching from sicily to brooklyn
to henderson to the home of maryland
langler
yes my mother i don't know if everybody
knows that the person taping this is my
son but there's one part of my mother's
past still missing it's my grandmother
there are no pictures of anthony alcomo
he was my mother's maternal grandfather
when her husband was shot dead on the
street in brooklyn it was 1919 alcomo
was 26 years old that
still remains a mystery there's walter's
birth record pat salator offered to help
she is the president of the clark county
nevada genealogical society it helps
people like my mother learn how to
uncover our history even
somebody you wouldn't have thought has a
story
has a story
this journey began one saturday
afternoon in palo verde library's
heritage room what have you been able to
find
she's going to find out using a family
tree my mother filled out salator went
to work i kind of knew from looking at
what you've given me that you were going
to be more interested in the guy who got
shot exactly it's true modern genealogy
but there are people other people
looking for him a bit of ancestry.com
census records shipping logs from the
turn of the century newspaper articles
i'm excited but i don't know what i'm
looking at slowly anthony alcomo's past
appeared in the present that's when they
were married
but i wonder how his brother died turns
out anthony had a brother who was also
murdered just a year before his demise
really
and a huge family back in sicily
a family ghost can i get like a picture
of that slowly came to light oh
there you are now it's all in a handy
book a teacher's edition my mother plans
to use moving forward just the start of
turning nostalgia i have family
somewhere
that i don't know about into knowledge
john langler live local now